hello Giga Chads and welcome back to the
channel uh last video I blue balled you
guys harder than Margot Robbie and the
Wolf of Wall Street by only finishing
half of raft so today why don't we be
better than her and finish off the rest
of it let's go ahead and get into things
okay so let's get started so starting
off with this video I'm just gonna do a
quick overview of raft rights or more so
I guess just the setup for this type of
thing so as we recall from last time
there's a leader all the rights are
going to be going through that leader
and then we've also got some followers
and the key thing to note here is that
in a follower there's not necessarily a
guarantee that every single follower in
raft is going to have the most
up-to-date lock a certain amount of them
must and we'll touch upon why that's the
case however it is possible that you
have an behind follower like this guy
right here where the log is technically
stale because it doesn't include both
the operation and term number for a
given index as you can see the actual
operation and term numbers of the leader
look like this and so we're missing c22
which means that in the 22nd term so
meaning this leader right here we wrote
C in that uh basically area of the log
so
what does that actually mean about raft
rights well not only do rights have to
actually write to the log but more
importantly they also have to be able to
backfill the log so let's go ahead and
talk about how they would do that so as
you can see let's start on the left over
here we've got a leader and we have a
follower which has a non-up-to-date log
so let's imagine that the leader has
this right here on the left where this
is representing again the operations on
the top and the epoch number of the
leader that wrote them on the bottom and
similarly that means the follower is
just starting with this right here where
you have from the 20th term D was
written so something like that is
possible if this were a previous leader
that died in the middle of a right or
even just a follower of a right that
didn't go completely through the point
is we have to overwrite this incorrect
value and also write the new values as
shown right here
so like I mentioned rights in addition
to just writing the new value also
backfill logs so let's now talk about a
special invariant in raft that is very
important to keep the correctness of
this entire algorithm so it is going to
rely on a couple of facts one there is
only one liter per term we covered that
last video the reason there's only one
liter per term is because we need a
quorum of nodes to be elected leader and
within a term you can't obviously have
two quorums agreeing on the leader so
again one liter per turn additionally
like I just said before rights back fill
log any successful write that goes
through to a follower is going to
absolutely fill the log fully up to date
so what that means is that let's say we
have a leader and a potential follower
that we want to write to if those two
logs on the leader and the follower have
the same term number at the same index
they must be identical prior to that
index so let's say this is index I don't
know 10 and this is index 11 in this log
of the leader and then over here we've
got index 10 and index 11 on the log the
follower because index 10 has the same
term number
on both the leader and the follower we
know that everywhere to the left of
index 10 and everywhere to the left of
index 10 on both the leader and the
follower must be the same and the term
that we use to describe this part of the
log in raft is called the prefix at the
same time you can see that they start to
differ on the index right after that and
as a result we call this area the suffix
so these are two terms to keep in mind
but the point is keep this invariant in
your head if two logs are the same at a
given point they must be the same
everywhere before that point because
rights backfill logs and there is only
one liter which means that it is
inherently going to be the same leader
that wrote this index so it's going to
be the same leader that wrote all of the
log before it if it was out of date
okay
now that we have covered that let's look
at how rights actually work
so we're going to start with a leader
right here who is going to propose a
right
because it gets it from some client
and the client can just send that right
right over to the leader easy stuff okay
so the leader says I have the following
right c21 meaning that
basically I am c21 in the position that
is highest in the log up to this point
so that's right here
I have this as my most recent entry at
index 2 because this is 0 1 2.
and then now in addition to that right
d22 so the first thing that it's going
to do is send this to the top replica
over here and the top replica is going
to project this right why because it
doesn't actually have
at 0 1 2 it doesn't have c21 so it's
going to say no I don't agree with you
up to this point you cannot send me the
right please try again
and so now what the leader is going to
do is it's going to try again but like
so it's going to move the index one back
so instead of trying to say here I have
c21 it's going to say hey I have B20 so
my prefix is going to be B20 and the
suffix is c21 and d22 and then it's
going to send that over right so prefix
is going to be a B20 and then the suffix
is going to be C and D
and then this time around because of the
fact that they agree on their prefixes
we know that the follower and the leader
have the same log from B20 and before so
we only have to send over our suffix and
the reason this is useful the reason we
do this whole thing instead of just
sending the whole log in the beginning
is because of the fact that it just
saves a ton of network latency if we had
to send the whole log every time we
would be sending a ton of data over the
network so instead what we just send is
the suffix and now this guy can actually
respond yes instead and so the leader
says okay I've adjusted what rights I'm
sending to you I'm good to go
additionally it is now also going to
send out c21 like before
as the prefix
and d22
as the suffix to this bottom node since
the bottom node has already been
backfilled sufficiently it already has
c21 at index 2. we can go ahead and
respond yes right here and the leader
can keep track of that so basically how
this works is like so if the leader
hears yes from a quorum of nodes it can
commit that right locally and it can
also tell the other nodes to commit that
right until then it's like a two-phase
commit where you know once you respond
yes for the first time you're waiting
you have the right locally but it's not
committed and then finally once you hear
back saying commit
then you go and do d22
so it's pretty simple stuff actually the
whole point here is that for a right to
survive it needs to go to a majority of
nodes and that allows us to keep our
invariant intact as long as we have a
right on a majority of nodes it means
that any leader that gets elected in the
future will have that right why because
a leader needs a majority of nodes to
get elected and when you have a majority
of nodes that are willing to elect you
because your log is equally or more up
to date than theirs that means that the
leader's log must include every single
right that has been committed hence why
this thing is considered technically
correct
so let's talk about some conclusions of
raft because obviously it is a
complicated system and it has its uses
so one raft creates fault tolerant
linearizable storage the entire point of
this thing is to build this guy right
here a distributed lock because when we
can order our rights and we can make
sure that those rights are never going
away we have a ton of super useful
properties of our database that allows
us to ensure correctness and build
systems on top of that those are going
to be for future videos but I'm looking
forward to covering those another thing
is that raft is slow going back to the
previous diagram everything has to go
through our single leader All rights and
depending on the raft implementation all
reads as well and so if that's the case
it means that you're basically
bottlenecked by one single node even
though your system is correct and even
though it's fault tolerated it's not
performing which means you don't want to
generally use something like raft as a
kind of General database implement
education for your application it's
better as a very specific kind of
nuanced piece of your application for
code that specifically needs to be
correct
and then finally even though raft is
Fault tolerant it does not replace
two-phase commit so recall that
two-phase commit is one where instead of
needing the majority of nodes to say yes
we need every single node to say yes and
so if a node says no
things are not going to go through this
right is not going to happen why does
rafts not replace two-phase commit
because raft is made to create a
distributed lock where the distributed
log is equal on every single system on
the other hand two-phase commit can
actually deal with heterogeneous rights
meaning that as opposed to just making a
log although you could and it's not very
fault tolerant so you probably shouldn't
you can actually send different rights
to different nodes and what that allows
you to do is something like cross
partition
distributed transactions
so feel free to watch the sharding video
but the point is oftentimes if you need
to make two different rights to two
different partitions you would have to
use something like two-phase command now
again you could use two-phase commit
combined with raft if you wanted to use
raft to basically deal with your
replication to be strongly consistent
there but even still you are eventually
just going to have to deal with
two-phase commit at some point
so yeah that is pretty much all for this
video guys
I am extremely tired as per usual
whenever I make a video on the weekday
so I am probably going to knock the
out but I will see you guys in the next
one